today member states agreed to ratify the
Paris agreement as soon as possible and
we once again stress the importance for
member states to start taking the
necessary steps to finalize their
respective ratification procedures with
this council statement all Member States
recall the global political commitments
to fight climate change and make use of
the momentum of the historic outcome
that was reached in Paris with the
first-ever global and legally binding
climate agreement we need to have an
improved ETH system as of 2020 with the
right stimulus to lower carbon dioxide
emissions and therefore i'm happy to
mention that many member states
underlines the importance of flexibility
so that the EU can keep up with the
dynamic process we agreed upon in Paris
the council has welcomed the action plan
of the Commission for facilitating the
transition to a clear economy and the
council has expressed commitment to do
what needs to be done to achieve this
transition I start with wildlife
trafficking and here I very much welcome
that these conclusions are put forward
for adoption by des ministres only a few
months after the commission presented
the ambitious action plan on our fight
against wildlife trafficking the
Commission's proposal for a revamped
national emissions healing directive
aims at reducing the health impacts
through significant reductions in
cross-border air pollution across the
European Union member states at today's
environment Council there was broad
support for continuing negotiations with
a view to concluding before hopefully
the end of June